do you remember the first time that you
ever I don't know you were singing and
somebody kind of was like wait you're
like really good at that
they're young on X Factor right yeah I
was like 16 on the show yeah
um that's crazy when I think about it
yeah
[Applause]
even drive or maybe you could I don't
know God he was terrible no he's awesome
so yeah no I guess it was kind of like I
remember one time my aunt lives in New
York and she would come over to Ireland
every summer with her kids and we'd like
take little road trips around Ireland I
remember like I don't know why she's
thought this but I was singing I've Got
Friends in Low life I started singing
and for some reason she thought I it was
I was the radio oh my gosh she thought
like it was on the radio and she thought
I was the radio that would have given me
so much confidence which is crazy
because I hadn't even hit puberty and I
still sounded like Garth Brooks
yeah that was nuts and I remember like
my teacher at school that was like
running the choir she kind of took me
under her wing and told me I was decent
so then it kind of took yeah that was it
I kind of me too that was kind of my
thing too yeah yeah just a car kid yeah
school plays and all that stuff yeah
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
guys I'm going
[Music]